now that they've gone through this
journey and they've changed and they've
reached their goal or they've failed to
reach their goal now what are they doing
do you believe the writer should know
the ending before starting a story I do
not everyone would agree with me some
people believe in free writing right so
some people believe hey just get on the
page and just start writing the only
reason I don't believe in that is
because I believe that it can discourage
you if you don't know where you're going
and especially if you're new at this
like if you've been doing this forever
you might not mind going to the page
writing and ended up being nowhere it's
not going to discourage you and you're
going to be able to go back and start
again but for people who are new at this
for people who have to work on deadlines
for people who are work for hire so
they're doing they're working on someone
else's stuff and not their own having a
plan is helpful and just like Google
Maps if I can't put in my end location
then it can't tell me where to go so I
think it's very important to know where
you're going that doesn't mean it won't
change right I might decide I'm on my
way to Target in the middle of that
decide I want to go to Walmart
right and that's okay but I knew I was
going to Target so I'm headed in that
direction and if I need to make a change
I can make a change I can always detour
but I think if you know the end goal and
you know how that's the work that's the
pre-work that's what you're doing and
you know we we offer workshops at the
work workbooks at the professional pen
that can help you through your pre-work
right that pre-work before you even get
to your outline is asking you how right
so you might know
even if it's a Marvel film that they're
gonna beat the bad guy
if you don't know how what are you
writing to right like how do you get
them there if you don't know how they're
going to beat the bad guy so in my
opinion it's very important to know
where you're going so when you look at a
first draft from someone who's come to
you for Scripps consultation can you
kind of always intuitively know or maybe
not even just it's just very glaringly
obvious who had the ending planned out
in the beginning and who it the the
voices told them the characters told
them yeah yeah I think
some people if you know structure you
don't have to have it planned out I can
tell that you don't know where this
screenplay is going
if you do know where it's going I might
not know if you always knew you know I
might not see that in writing that you
always knew where it was going because
that doesn't matter it doesn't matter if
you always knew if the script is here
and it's structured well and we get to
the end
and everything that they were supposed
to achieve or not achieve is there and
it's clear great what happens more so
more often is we go round and round and
round and then it finishes
right because they didn't know how they
were going to get there so even if they
know the end they didn't know the middle
right and so you can see that very
easily that sometimes all they knew was
then and they had no idea how they were
going to get to the end right so it's
all the stuff in the middle or sometimes
it is that everything is going pretty
well and then we get to the end and they
realize they didn't know how they didn't
know what to do once they got there and
so then it just ends and so then now
it's anticlimactic or the resolution
wasn't earned you know what I mean
because you gave me all this stuff and
then all of a sudden you just stopped
and it's probably because just got lost
because you didn't have a plan you
didn't know where you were going and now
you got to Target and you don't have a
list and now you're just wondering the
halls of Target and we already know
that's bad because now you're gonna end
up with more stuff in your basket than
you came there for and the same thing
kind of happens in the screenplay
how does the ending reflect the story's
central theme
so if you want to look at theme as the
dramatic question that the writer is
posing the audience then one of the ways
that you can show us that is through
your characters so if your main
character is on uh one side of the theme
and your antagonist or one of your sub
characters is on the other side of the
theme then the way it ends can tell us
who was right
or if no one was right and there and
it's supposed to be a gray area so one
of my uh favorite examples is Black
Panther right the first one
so King t'challa has been taught by his
ancestors that they should be saving
vibranium for just wakanda and that
their job is to only keep the people of
wakanda safe
and then killmonger the antagonist comes
in and says you have all of these
resources and you should be sharing them
you're selfish that you're not sharing
them both of those ideas make sense
right and our job as an audience is to
choose a side and as we see them
fighting throughout what's happening is
the themes are fighting I should only
keep my own people safe I'm responsible
for everybody that's what we're watching
throughout so in the end when um
t'challa kills killmonger that means the
idea that it's my job to keep my people
safe one
however we see in the resolution that he
decides to open up a little bit and it's
because of his journey of hearing
killmonger's point of view learning his
backstory and having his fight with him
that he was able to move his needle a
little bit one way or the other and say
yes it's my job to keep these people
safe but I can also probably be offering
more resources to other people so I
think that resolution should be showing
us you know some answers or purposefully
not so that we can then go home and have
a discussion about it right because
that's what you want people to do you
want people to be talking about was
killmonger right or was the child right
you know
how much thought should a writer put
into the tone they want the ending to
have yeah I think they I think tone is
going to matter period right especially
when it comes to which genre you're
considering if you're writing a comedy
and then you decide your the the tone of
your resolution is going to be really
low
then this is probably not a comedy you
know what I mean you have to figure out
how you can have a dramatic moment
that's still light enough that it works
in the tone of the entire screenplay so
you have to ask yourself and this is why
in Hollywood we use comps what is this
like
right whether what other movie what
other TV show and if you're really
artistic you can say what other what
song right what songs does this make me
feel like then you kind of know what
that tone is and then your job is to
kind of live in that tone throughout the
entire
throughout the entire script right
um to kind of stay in this is a light
story so even if something really
um traumatic happens the way they deal
with it the way that it happens the way
they heal from it is light right we're
not gonna go dark because then that
changes the tone so I think it's very
important to know the tone before you
start writing you should know the tone
before you start writing you should know
what kind of script this is going to be
so that you can make sure that every
scene every line of dialogue every
situation is gonna stay in that area of
tone is that something that you advise
the screenwriters that you work with to
do is to pick a song
whatever because tone is about feeling
so if I know like there's a a butterfly
by Mariah Carey I can't explain to you
what it makes me feel I know how it
makes me feel and since I'm an artist I
can probably write that feeling even if
I can't talk to you about it it's the
same thing if somebody reads a lot of
books you know or someone likes food
you know what cotton candy makes you
feel like versus what spinach makes you
feel like you know what a nice warm soup
on a cold day makes you feel like versus
ice cream on a cold day right doesn't
mean you don't like ice cream but it
might mean it's cold outside I don't
want something cold in me right so I say
for people now if you go into a pitch
what makes it unique is if you're able
to use other references other than just
films and TV if you go in and say that
it's this movie meets this song and it's
a song that everybody knows and it's a
movie that everybody knows now you've
got people going ah because we know how
that song makes us feel right we're all
going back to the societal thing we're
all kind of living in the same space and
time we know how those things make us
feel so any kind of thing that gives you
a feeling I say you can use for tone you
just need to be able to you know
communicate that you know when you're
well in your writing and when you're
pitching how does the ending connect to
the story's beginning yeah so some
people will specifically like bookend
right and how it starts they will
literally finish it that way some people
look at it as mirror images are
opposites and how it starts it's gonna
um be the exact opposite at the end in
my opinion doesn't have to be that
um I often tell people that they can do
a new normal at their end because all
films and stories should start with a
normal
would I be my normal is what were these
people doing whether the camera showed
up or not because they're supposed to be
people right they're not just your
characters they're people they're living
in the world the cameras weren't showing
up what would they be doing and so
during that setup in your act one if
we're talking about a feature then
you're showing me every day they would
be going to school every day they'd be
fighting with their mom every day like
whether we came here or not whether
there was an exciting incident or not
that's what they would be doing and so
then what you showed me at the end of
your uh script is now that they've gone
through this journey and they've changed
and they've reached their goal or
they've failed to reach their goal
now what are they doing what's their new
normal and so that gives you an
opportunity to show me what their Arc
was and how they grew now not everything
has a new normal if you're watching a a
suspense thriller then it might end when
the police sirens are in the background
right we don't get to see what happens
after that but I think writing a new
normal is a great opportunity to show
how your beginning was affected by your
end and I think it should be affected
but I don't think you always have to
show us sometimes like again in the
suspense thriller if the bad guy was
caught or is dead now I don't
necessarily need to know what else is
going on like I'm good right but if this
was a drama or a comedy that started off
showing me that this person
um lacked confidence
then maybe you know it's always easy to
use like a singing competition if they
weren't able to even stand on the stage
at the top of the movie but by the end
of the movie they're on the stage
rocking out then I'm able to put those
two things together and it kind of
really brings things back home and shows
you that the reason they needed to go on
this journey was to affect their normal